todo
[Música]
hola hoy en saints click los agujeros de
gusano
según la teoría de la relatividad
general nuestro universo es una empresa
perfil de cuatro dimensiones en la que
se mueven todos los objetos se trata del
espacio-tiempo el espacio-tiempo no es
totalmente rígido posee una cierta
geometría que puede distorsionarse en
presencia de masas y energía es decir
puede curvarse esta curvatura es la
responsable de la gravitación
un agujero negro es un objeto cuya masa
se consciente en un único punto al que
llamamos singularidad
debido a su gran masa los agujeros
negros distorsión en el espacio-tiempo a
su alrededor muy cerca del agujero negro
el espacio-tiempo se distorsiona tanto
que todos los objetos y hasta la luz no
pueden escapar
esto es el horizonte de sucesos del
agujero negro una esfera dentro de la
cual la curvatura de espacio-tiempo es
tan grande que se hace imposible escapar
de él
para visualizar mejor un agujero negro
podemos representar su geometría
haciendo lo que en matemáticas se
denomina un encaje
el encaje nos dará una forma geométrica
que representa con fidelidad cómo se
curva el espacio alrededor del agujero
negro
según las matemáticas constatamos que el
espacio alrededor de un agujero negro se
comporta esencialmente como un embudo a
gran distancia es prácticamente plano su
curvatura es apenas perceptible y cuanto
más nos acercamos al horizonte de
sucesos mayor es la atracción
gravitatoria
sorprendentemente podemos tener la
impresión de que es la propia estructura
del universo la que contiene un agujero
la existencia de este agujero puede
resultar extraño podemos preguntarnos
qué pasaría si una nave espacial llegara
a su orden acaso el universo se detiene
en este agujero
[Música]
para responder a esta pregunta es
necesario comprender una cierta sutileza
matemática
nuestro universo posee cuatro
dimensiones tres dimensiones de espacio
y una dimensión de tiempo al representar
la geometría del espacio pasamos por
alto dos de estas dimensiones
por un lado el horizonte de sucesos del
agujero negro es una esfera pero aquí
para poder representar el espacio-tiempo
hemos suprimido una de las dimensiones
del espacio el horizonte de sucesos se
convierte en un círculo
además solo hemos representado la
curvatura del espacio pero no la del
tiempo hemos pasado por alto
voluntariamente la dimensión temporal de
nuestro diagrama en consecuencia el
diagrama es estático representa la
curvatura del espacio en un solo
instante del tiempo
al caer hacia el agujero negro nuestra
nave espacial avanza hacia adelante en
el tiempo de hecho si el tiempo no
fluyera la nave espacial permanecería
inmóvil así cuando observamos el
descenso de la nave espacial a medida
que transcurre el tiempo es necesario
que nuestro encaje evolucione igualmente
de manera que siga representando la
curvatura del espacio-tiempo en cada
instante
si hacemos evolucionar nuestro diagrama
de este modo nos damos cuenta de que el
agujero negro se cierra sobre sí mismo
muy rápidamente al alcanzar el horizonte
de sucesos del agujero negro la nave
espacial sigue viajando a través de él y
continúa su descenso hacia la
singularidad central
[Música]
matemáticamente se puede demostrar que
independientemente del observador este
tipo de agujeros en el universo se
cerrará siempre sobre sí mismo a una
velocidad tan grande que será
inalcanzable
según la relatividad general la
estructura del espacio permite la
existencia de este tipo de agujeros pero
éstos deben cerrarse en definitiva sobre
sí mismos con extrema rapidez de forma
que sea imposible alcanzarlos
así pues el universo no contiene
realmente ningún agujero pero tanto para
nuestra imaginación como para la
elegancia matemática esto no es muy
satisfactorio aunque se cierre sobre sí
mismo con gran rapidez el agujero parece
existir durante un corto instante lo
cual resulta extraño
nos da la impresión de que falta algo en
nuestra teoría que no describe
perfectamente la situación
en las matemáticas es posible duplicar
la geometría del espacio en nuestras
ecuaciones
es posible copiarla solo que en sentido
inverso en esta versión invertida la
copia el agujero negro se comporta de
forma distinta en vez de no poder
escapar de su interior todos los objetos
están por el contrario destinados a
escapar de él esto es lo que llamamos un
agujero blanco
[Música]
teniendo esta copia del espacio-tiempo
podemos insertar la debajo de nuestro
agujero original
este razonamiento matemático es
ciertamente artificioso y no puede ser
fácilmente respaldado por ningún tipo de
observación física se trata simplemente
de una extensión matemática motivada por
la simetría de las ecuaciones
se forma una estructura mucho más
satisfactoria con la forma de un tubo en
lugar de un agujero sencillo es este
tipo de estructura a la que llamamos
agujero de gusano
si está la estructura existiese entonces
el agujero de gusano tendría que
conectar inevitablemente dos partes del
espacio-tiempo entre sí es posible que
conecte dos universos independientes
pero también está active que conecte dos
partes diferentes de un mismo universo
formaría un atajo geométrico entre estas
dos regiones que la luz y los objetos
podrían utilizar para viajar más
rápidamente de un lugar a otro
si damos rienda suelta a nuestra
imaginación podríamos fantasear con un
futuro en el que las naves espaciales
puedan atravesar tales atajos en un
espacio-tiempo para viajes
intergalácticos
sin embargo este agujero de gusano
formado por un agujero negro y no blanco
también conocido como puente de ice and
grow ser no puede ser atravesado como
hemos visto anteriormente su estructura
con forma de tubo se cierra sobre sí
misma con extrema rapidez
estrangulando así cualquier objeto que
se aventure en su interior así pues es
imposible cruzarlo y lo único que se
consigue es descender hacia la
singularidad del agujero negro
afortunadamente para la curiosidad
existen otras geometrías para agujeros
de gusano que son matemáticamente
viables según la relatividad general y
cuyas propiedades son más ventajosas
en primer lugar si un agujero negro gira
sobre sí mismo o si posee una carga
eléctrica entonces podría ser posible
atravesar su agujero de gusano asociado
en este caso la singularidad central no
es un punto fijo sino un anillo que
genera a su alrededor un nuevo horizonte
a través del cual podría ser posible
pasar
dicho esto este agujero de gusano sólo
sería transitable en una dirección no
sería posible viajar en el otro sentido
a través del agujero blanco los físicos
teóricos han ideado geometrías más
sofisticadas con propiedades aún más
interesantes para permitir un verdadero
viaje a través del espacio-tiempo
estos agujeros de gusano son puramente
matemáticos y están pensados para
obedecer ciertas condiciones de
viabilidad en primer lugar buscamos que
nuestro agujero de gusano sea cruz hable
en ambos sentidos
a diferencia del puente einstein glows
en éste debe ser desprovisto de
cualquier tipo de horizonte de sucesos
para que cualquier punto sea cruz hablé
en un sentido o en el otro
en segundo lugar el agujero de gusano
debe ser estable en el tiempo en efecto
si se cierra sobre sí mismo o si es
inestable sería muy arriesgado viajar a
través de él
en tercer lugar para ser capaz de
cruzarlo sin problemas el tubo que forma
el agujero de gusano tiene que ser lo
suficientemente ancho de lo contrario
sería sencillamente imposible caber en
él en cuarto lugar el tiempo necesario
para cruzar este agujero de gusano debe
ser razonable unos pocos años por
ejemplo si el viaje dura miles de
millones de años el agujero de gusano no
sería de gran utilidad
por último las fuerzas gravitacionales
generadas por su geometría no deben ser
demasiado fuertes para que no dañen o
vestir en la estructura de la nave
espacial que viaja por el agujero de
gusano
matemáticamente existen tales geometrías
aceptadas por la teoría de la
relatividad general
uno de los ejemplos más sencillos es el
agujero de gusano de maurice store
el agujero de gusano de morris storm
posee una serie de propiedades muy
interesantes no tiene horizonte de
sucesos ni singularidades y es
perfectamente estable en el tiempo no se
cierra sobre sí mismo mientras un objeto
lo atraviesa
este tipo de agujero de gusano es
particularmente interesante ya que es
puramente geométrico su peculiar
estructura no le permite generar una
atracción gravitatoria
por ello es posible permanecer inmóviles
junto un agujero de gusano de este tipo
sin que nos arrastre o nos repele
cuando intentemos cruzarlo nuestra nave
espacial se moverá a lo largo de una
geodésica una línea recta dentro de la
curva del espacio-tiempo las lineas
geodésicas del agujero de gusano de
mobile storm son particularmente
interesantes
ciertas trayectorias se entrarán darán
vueltas en su interior pero acabarán
saliendo del tubo por el mismo extremo
por el que entraron
al no generar una atracción gravitatoria
que arrastra las cosas es necesario
dirigir la nave espacial precisamente
hacia el centro del agujero para
atravesarlo
a simple vista al igual que por un
agujero negro los rayos de luz son
desviados por esta geometría el agujero
de gusano actúa como una lente que
distorsiona la imagen de las estrellas
vecinas no obstante dado que los rayos
de luz también pueden atravesarlo
podemos llegar a observar una imagen de
las entidades que se encuentran al otro
lado del agujero de gusano visualizando
así la parte del universo con la que
enlaza
el agujero de gusano de maurice storm
parece reunir todas las condiciones
necesarias para la viabilidad de los
viajes intergalácticos
pero no es tan sencillo su existencia
depende de hecho de que sea estable
ubicando a su alrededor una esfera de
energía negativa
esta energía negativa es necesaria para
contrarrestar la atención del
espacio-tiempo que obliga continuamente
a las estructuras de este tipo a
colapsar sobre sí mismas como vimos con
el puente de einstein closed por
desgracia según la relatividad general
se puede demostrar que esa energía
negativa es matemáticamente imposible
lo que significa que no pueden existir
agujeros de gusano estables
por decepcionante que pueda parecernos
los agujeros de gusano son pues
imposibles ya que su existencia en
cuanto a estructuras estables depende de
la existencia de energía negativa lo
cual es matemáticamente imposible
este principio se denomina como teorema
de la censura topo lógica nos dice que
cualquier tipo de estructura similar a
un agujero de gusano se autocensura se
cerrará sobre sí misma para cualquier
observador que intenta alcanzarla
pero estas conclusiones finales se basan
en la relatividad general
ahora bien somos conscientes de que esta
teoría no es perfecta no tiene en cuenta
ciertos fenómenos cuánticos que se
producen a escalas microscópicas a
dichas escalas surgen otras teorías como
la teoría cuántica de campos
según esta teoría que describe las
partículas al nivel cuántico los vacíos
poseen una cierta energía que se agita
constantemente mediante fluctuaciones
estas fluctuaciones se conocen como
partículas virtuales se asemejan a las
partículas ordinarias pero aparecen y
desaparecen con suma rapidez
todas estas partículas virtuales generan
una especie de presión residual en el
espacio que en determinadas
configuraciones actúan igual que una
energía negativa a esto se le conoce
como el efecto casimir
así aunque la relatividad general parece
rechazar la posibilidad de agujeros de
gusano estables los fenómenos cuánticos
podrían aportar una solución al problema
algunos científicos ya imaginan
paralelismos entre los agujeros de
gusano y el fenómeno del entrelazamiento
cuántico
además algunas teorías más especulativas
como la teoría de cuerdas por ejemplo
ofrecen nuevas perspectivas para
conceptualizar la existencia natural de
agujeros de gusano que se habrían
formado justo después del big bang y que
se habrían estirado tras su creación por
la expansión del universo
estos agujeros de gusano se
estabilizarían mediante cuerdas cósmicas
que por ahora siguen siendo objetos
totalmente hipotéticos
por último si la existencia de los
agujeros de gusano pudiera demostrarse
realmente se plantearía la cuestión del
viaje en el tiempo en efecto la teoría
de la relatividad que no actúa sobre el
espacio sino sobre el espacio-tiempo no
impide que un objeto de este tipo enlace
dos instantes diferentes en el tiempo no
sabemos aún si sería posible o no viajar
al pasado pero los agujeros de gusano
podrían hacer lo posible dicho esto por
razones de coherencia un agujero de
gusano nunca podría llevar a los
viajeros más atrás en el pasado que el
momento mismo de su creación
los agujeros de gusano son objetos
fascinantes desde el punto de vista
matemático su estudio sigue siendo muy
especulativo pero no obstante nos
permite reforzar nuestras teorías
actuales al ponerlas constantemente a
prueba y tratar de superar sus límites
aun cuando la existencia de los agujeros
de gusano no debe descartarse por
completo por el momento los únicos
capaces de atravesar agujeros de gusano
son los físicos teóricos usando
ecuaciones como naves espaciales
[Música]